Trascrizione: Mohamed Badr
Revisore: Deborah Sciacero
La gentilezza.
La vita è stata molto gentile con me.
Sono nato e cresciuto in
una famiglia gentile.
Mi ha mostrato la gentilezza,
me l'ha insegnata.
Erano gentili, sono gentili tra di loro.
Gentili, ovviamente con noi,
con me, mia sorella,
ma gentili, con un animale domestico,
con un vasetto di gerani.
Gentili.
Sono nato e cresciuto in
una città gentile.
Torino.
Una bellissima città che mi ha offerto
davvero grandissime opportunità,
mi ha entusiasmato, mi ha intrattenuto,
mi ha intrattenuto parecchio, anzi.
Piccola parentesi.
Credo di aver contribuito attivamente
a quell’intrattenimento.
Sono certo che qui ci saranno almeno
un po’ di persone a cui ho servito
un cocktail superalcolico
a un’ora improbabile del mattino
nel cuore pulsante dei Murazzi,
di inizio millennio.
La vita è stata gentile con me
perché mi ha sempre
permesso di tornare a casa sani
salvo da quelle serate.
La vita, poi ha continuato
a essere gentile con me.
Perché mi ha fatto scoprire una passione.
E sono riuscito a trasformare
quella passione nel mio lavoro.
Una vera fortuna.
Ve lo auguro con tutto il cuore.
E così, un giorno di ormai un bel po’
di tempo fa, più di dieci anni fa,
che è un periodo relativamente breve, se
si paragona alla maratona che è la vita,
ho raggiunto la vera consapevolezza
di tutta questa fortuna,
di questa gentilezza che avevo ricevuto,
e allora è nato in me,
in modo piuttosto improvviso,
un forte desiderio di di restituirla.
Quella gentilezza, quella fortuna.
Ero a Parigi, stavo girando un film
ed è venuto a trovarmi,
era lì per lavoro,
un mio amico fraterno
e ci siamo seduti al tavolino
di un caffè parigino.
Abbiamo iniziato a parlare,
ci siamo resi conto parlando
che eravamo arrivati,
per vie completamente diverse,
allo stesso punto, nello stesso momento.
Avevamo entrambi quell'esigenza,
l'esigenza di restituire.
Da quella chiacchiera,
è nata una scintilla.
Da quella scintilla, è nata un’idea.
Ed è iniziata così.
In Italia ci sono, solo in Italia,
oltre 400.000 piccole e medie
associazioni no profit
che si applicano tutti i giorni per
risolvere qualche problema concreto,
molto concreto.
E allora, chiacchierando seduti a quel
tavolino di un bar, ci siamo detti:
“Ma pensa che se tutti offrissimo
anche solo un caffè,
quello che stiamo bevendo,
a qualcuno che ne ha veramente bisogno.
Sarebbe rivoluzionario.
E così poco più di dieci anni fa,
è nata “Un caffè“
si chiama così la nostra associazione.
Ed è un’idea piuttosto semplice,
ma che continua
a entusiasmarmi totalmente,
continua a farmi
venire voglia di raccontarla.
È un'idea semplice, perché si basa
su tre principi molto basilari.
Uno.
Insieme si genera più energia che da soli.
Due.
Piccolo non significa inferiore
E tre,
è che il piacere di donare dura
sempre di più del piacere di ricevere.
È nata “Un caffè”, dieci anni fa
nella prima, primissima realtà digitale,
una piattaforma di crowdfunding destinata
a piccole e medie associazioni italiane.
Viene alimentata attraverso,
la alimentiamo, la diffusione
della cultura del gesto, del dono.
All’inizio, ovviamente, ci siamo ispirati
alla bellissima tradizione napoletana
del caffè sospeso,
quella tradizione per la quale
si entra in un bar,
si ordina un caffè per sé,
poi se ne lascia pagato uno
per qualcuno che non se lo può permettere.
Abbiamo preso questa idea, l’abbiamo resa
questa piattaforma di crowdfunding
e ogni settimana diamo la possibilità
a chiunque di lasciare un caffè pagato.
Oltre a quelli che ovviamente
lasciamo noi.
In questi dieci anni abbiamo sostenuto
più di 800 progetti
ed è stato un viaggio incredibile.
Non bastano certo questi 10 minuti per
raccontarvi tutto quello
che siamo riusciti a fare.
Ci siamo resi conto però di essere
riusciti a rendere, in alcuni casi,
l’impossibile possibile,
perché una ragazza disabile,
che tra l’altro è qui presente oggi,
non dovrebbe poter
fare il cammino di Santiago.
Basta qualche caffè, basta qualche
volontario con le gambe buone
e l’impossibile diventa possibile.
Oppure magari non avete mai sentito
parlare di Felicetto. Felicetto
È un coloratissimo autobus, guidato da dei
volontari con il naso rosso da clown,
che si occupa di portare ragazzi e bambini
del Salento verso il luogo di cura.
Oppure non potete capire l'emozione di
vedere dei piccoli malati oncologici
prendere il diploma del piccolo aviatore
di nuovo grazie a dei volontari
che li portano su un aereo
e li fanno volare.
Insomma, di nuovo non basterebbe.
Non basterebbe una settimana per
raccontarvi tutto questo.
E raccontarlo
non è un semplice compiacimento.
Proprio per provare a farvi capire
che con un piccolissimo gesto
si possono fare delle cose straordinarie.
Prendo ancora un minuto
per raccontarvi
un’altra costola importante
di Un caffè” in questi anni.
In questi dieci anni ci siamo resi conto,
lavorando,
che le associazioni avevano
delle esigenze molto concrete.
Non solo avevano bisogno
di una raccolta fondi o di comunicazione.
Avevano proprio delle esigenze materiali.
Avevano un sito da rifare, avevano
uno statuto da descrivere meglio.
E allora?
È nato, Campo base.
Campo base, in montagna, è quel luogo dove
si raccolgono tutti i materiali
che servono per poi raggiungere la vetta.
Si prepara la vera spedizione
verso la cima.
A pochissima distanza da qua.
Nel Parco del Valentino, nascerà
la nuova sede di Campo Base
al villino del Caprifoglio.
E chi entrerà,
speriamo che alcuni di voi ci aiuteranno,
Troverà una bacheca, una tabella
con solo scritto chi cerca e chi dona.
Un vero co-working di solidarietà.
Ci sarà bisogno di un commercialista
per scrivere quello statuto.
Ci sarà bisogno di un web designer
per rifare quel sito.
Cosa abbiamo imparato in
questi dieci anni?
Abbiamo imparato che
è meglio iniziare la giornata
senza l’aspettativa di ricevere qualcosa,
ma con l’intenzione di donare qualcosa.
Abbiamo imparato che è inutile vivere
con la delusione di non aver avuto.
È più bello e più divertente vivere
con il piacere di donare
e non serve donare necessariamente
qualcosa di grande o del denaro.
Basta un sorriso, un grazie, per piacere.
Un gesto di gentilezza, appunto.
E vale non soltanto per qualcuno
che ne ha bisogno.
Vale per un familiare, per un amico,
per un parente, per uno sconosciuto.
Abbiamo imparato che se lo facciamo tutti,
allora diventa veramente potente.
La vita continua a essere gentile con me.
La mia città è diventata il mondo.
Sono pieno di amici veri che continuano
a stimolarmi, a insegnarmi tante cose.
Amo e sono amato da una splendida donna
che è diventata mia moglie.
Ho una figlia meravigliosa,
ho il cuore pieno, insomma.
Però sono certo che chiunque,
qua questa sera, possa trovare
dentro di sé un motivo per sentire
la gentilezza che
la vita ha avuto con voi.
E allora vi invito a provare a scoprire
il piacere di restituirne
un po’ agli altri.
Vi assicuro che sarà potente.
Grazie.